[MUSIC PLAYING]
VUYILE: My name is Vuyile.
I'm working as a security guard.
But at the same time,
I'm selling airtime.
Thank you.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH]
VUYILE: I love Nomanini because
they changed my life a lot.
MALE SPEAKER 1: In Siswati,
Nomanini means any time.
Much of Africa, the really
essential services that
are being provided using
pre-paid payment mechanisms,
like mobile telephony,
electricity, and even water,
are provided not by the state,
but by informal entrepreneurs.
The poorer you were
and the farther you
were from business
centers, the more expensive
it was for you to
access these services.
And that really
resonates with Nomanini,
where you can make
those payments
available and
affordable everywhere.
MALE SPEAKER 2: We've developed
a point-of-sale terminal.
And the products is delivered
wirelessly at the time
when people need it.
People rely on us
to earn an income.
And posting our application
on Google Cloud Platform
gives us a much
higher reliability
than we could have got
hosting it ourselves.
Month after month, we've had
100% uptime on our production
application.
And I know that we
wouldn't have been
able to do that on our own.
VUYILE: My customers
know me very well.
They just call me and
say, hey, Mr. Airtime!
MALE SPEAKER 2: We started
off with one release a month
in 2011 to 6 to
10 releases a day.
And that's been a
huge advantage for us.
Google Cloud Platform
helps with that
because this makes
releasing code simple.
MALE SPEAKER 1: We
respect the end user a lot
and we look very closely
at the merchant's needs.
MALE SPEAKER 2: We've managed
to turn around the product,
take feedback from the market,
and solve a brand new business
need, a need our consumers have.
VUYILE: I help a lot of people.
I've got everything what I
need because of Nomanini.